Je croyais qu'il y aurait un podium, j'ai donc un peu peur.
(Rires)
Chris m'a demandé de raconter, encore une fois, comment nous avons trouvé la structure de l'ADN.
Puisque, vous savez, j'obéis à ses ordres, je le ferai
mais ça m'ennuie un peu.
(Rires)
Vous savez, j'ai écrit un livre mais je dirai quelque chose...
Je raconterai un peu comment la découverte a été faite
et pourquoi Francis et moi l'avons trouvée.
Ensuite, j'espère qu'il me restera au moins 5 minutes pour dire
ce qui m'intéresse maintenant.
Derrière, il y a une photo de moi lorsque j'avais 17 ans.
J'étais à l'Université de Chicago, durant ma 3ème année,
et j'étais en 3ème année parce que l'Université de Chicago
vous laisse entrer après deux ans de secondaire.
C'était plaisant de fuir le secondaire
parce que j'étais très petit et pas bon en sports
ni en choses du genre.
Je devrais vous dire au sujet de mon milieu familial : mon père avait été
élevé pour devenir Épiscopalien et Républicain
mais après une année d'études, il est devenu athée et Démocrate.
(Rires)
Ma mère était catholique irlandaise
mais elle ne prenait pas la religion trop au sérieux.
Dès l'âge de 11 ans, je n'allais plus à la messe du dimanche,
j'allais plutôt en randonnées d'observation d'oiseaux avec mon père
de sorte que, très jeune, j'ai entendu parler de Charles Darwin.
Vous savez, il était le grand héros.
Nous comprenons la vie telle qu'elle existe maintenant grâce à l'évolution.
A l'Université de Chicago, je me suis spécialisé en zoologie.
Je croyais que je finirais, si j'étais asssez brillant,
peut-être avec un doctorat de Cornell en ornithologie.
Puis, un journal de Chicago a publié la critique d'un livre
intitulé "Qu'est-ce que la Vie ?" du grand physicien Schrödinger.
C'était, bien sûr, une question que je voulais connaître.
Vous savez, Darwin expliquait la vie après qu'elle eut commencé
mais quelle était l'essence de la vie ?
Schrödinger disait que l'essence était l'information
présente dans nos chromosomes et qu'elle devait être présente
sur une molécule. Je n'avais jamais vraiment pensé aux molécules.
Vous connaisssez les chromosomes, mais il s'agissait-là d'une molécule,
et d'une façon ou d'une autre toute l'information était probablement présente
sous une forme numérique. Voilà la grande question :
comment pouvez-vous recopier l'information ?
C'était donc ça le livre. A partir de ce moment,
je voulais devenir généticien,
comprendre le gène et ainsi comprendre la vie.
J'avais un héros lointain.
Ce n'était pas un joueur de baseball, c'était Linus Pauling.
J'ai donc posé ma candidature à Caltech et ils m'ont refusé.
(Rires)
Je me suis inscrit à Indiana,
qui était en fait aussi bonne que Caltech en génétique
et, d ailleurs, ils avaient une très bonne équipe de basket.
J'ai donc eu une vie très agréable à Indiana.
C'est à Indiana que j'ai eu l'impression que
le gène serait probablement de l'ADN.
Après ma thèse, je voulais aller explorer cet ADN.
Je me suis d'abord rendu à Copenhague parce que je pensais
que je pouvais peut-être devenir biochimiste
mais j'ai découvert que la biochimie était très ennuyeuse.
Ça n'allait pas vers une description de ce qu'était le gène.
Ce n'était que de la science nucléaire. Oh, c'est le petit livre.
Vous pouvez le lire en deux heures.
A ce moment, je suis allé à une réunion en Italie.
Il y avait là un conférencier imprévu qui n'était pas au programme
et il a parlé de l'ADN.
Il s'agissait de Maurice Wilkins. Il avait une formation de physicien :
après la guerre, il a voulu faire de la biophysique et il a choisi l'ADN
parce que l'ADN avait été reconnu à l'Institut Rockfeller
comme formant probablement les molécules génétiques sur les chromosomes.
La plupart des gens croyaient que c'était les protéines
mais Wilkins, lui, croyait qu'il y avait de fortes chances que ce soit l'ADN.
Il montra cette radio :
une sorte de réseau cristallin. L'ADN avait donc la structure,
quoiqu'elle la devait probablement à différentes molécules
portant différents ensembles d'instructions.
Il y avait donc quelque chose d'universel dans la molécule d'ADN.
Je voulais donc travailler avec lui mais il ne voulait pas d'un ex-ornithologue
et j'ai abouti à Cambridge en Angleterre.
Je suis donc allé à Cambridge
parce que c'était alors le meilleur endroit au monde
pour la cristallographie par diffraction de rayons X - qui est maintenant une discipline
dans nos départements de chimie.
À cette période, c'était le domaine des physiciens.
Le meilleur endroit pour la cristallographie par diffraction de rayons X
était au Laboratoire Cavendish de Cambridge.
C'est là que j'ai rencontré Francis Crick.
J'y suis allé sans le connaître. Il avait 35 ans. J'en avais 23.
En moins d'une journée, nous avions décidé que
nous pourrions peut-être prendre un raccourci pour trouver la structure de l'ADN.
Non pas la résoudre de façon rigoureuse mais en construire un modèle.
Un électro-modèle utilisant des coordonnées, vous savez,
de longueurs, des choses tirées des clichés de rayons X.
Poser des questions sur la molécule - comment doit-elle se replier ?
Ce qui nous motivait, au centre de cette photo,
c'est Linus Pauling. Environ 6 mois plus tôt, il proposait
la structure alpha hélicoïdale pour les protéines. Ce faisant,
il rejetait l'homme à droite,
Sir Lawrence Bragg, qui était le professeur de Cavendish.
Voici une photo prise plusieurs années plus tard
lorsque Bragg avait une raison de sourire.
Il n'était certainement pas souriant lorsque je suis arrivé là
car il avait été humilié par Pauling, qui avait trouvé l'hélice alpha,
et par l'échec des gens de Cambridge, qui n'étaient pas chimistes.
Assurément, ni Crick ni moi n'étions chimistes,
nous avons donc tenté de construire un modèle. Francis connaissait Wilkins.
Wilkins disait qu'il croyait que c'était l'hélice.
Le diagramme de rayons X, croyait-il, était comparable à l'hélice.
Nous avons donc construit un modèle à trois brins.
Les gens de Londres sont arrivés.
Wilkins et cette collaboratrice, ou possible collaboratrice,
Rosalind Franklin, sont arrivés et ils ont ri de notre modèle.
Ils disaient qu'il était faible. Il l'était.
On nous a dit de ne plus construire de modèles, que nous étions incompétents.
(Rires)
Alors, nous n'avons plus construit de modèles
et Francis a continué son travail sur les protéines.
Essentiellement, je ne faisais rien. Sauf lire.
Vous savez, essentiellement, lire est une bonne chose ; vous amassez des faits.
Nous répétions aux gens de Londres
que Linus Pauling se dirigeait vers l'ADN.
Si l'ADN est si important, Linus le saura.
Il construira un modèle et nous allons perdre le scoop.
En effet, il avait écrit aux gens de Londres :
Pouvait-il voir leur cliché de rayons X ?
Ils ont eu la sagesse de dire "non". Il ne l'a donc pas eu
mais il y en avait dans la littérature.
En fait, Linus ne les a pas regardés très attentivement
mais environ 15 mois après mon arrivée à Cambridge,
une rumeur commença à se répandre, venant du fils de Linus Pauling,
qui était à Cambridge, selon laquelle son père travaillait maintenant sur l'ADN.
Un jour, Peter est entré en disant qu'il était Peter Pauling.
Il m'a donné une copie des manuscrits de son père.
Comme j'ai eu peur, pensant, vous savez, que nous pouvions perdre le scoop.
Je n'ai rien à faire, aucune compétence pour quoi que ce soit.
(Rires)
Il y avait ce papier, il proposait une structure à 3 brins.
Je l'ai lu, et c'était simplement... de la merde.
(Rires)
C'était surprenant, venant d'une sommité,
et ça tenait ensemble par des liaisons hydrogène
entre des groupes de phosphate.
Eh bien, si le pH maximum des cellules est d'environ 7,
ces liaisons hydrogène ne pouvaient pas exister.
Nous avons couru au département de chimie et dit :
"Pauling pourrait-il avoir raison ?" Alex Hust a dit "Non". Nous étions donc heureux.
(Rires)
Nous étions donc encore dans la course mais nous avions peur
que quelqu'un à Caltech dirait à Linus qu'il faisait erreur.
Bragg a donc dit : "Construisez des modèles."
Un mois après avoir reçu le manuscrit de Pauling -
je dois dire que j'ai apporté le manuscrit à Londres et l'ai montré aux gens -
je leur dit que Linus se trompait, que nous étions encore dans la course
et qu'ils devraient commencer immédiatement à construire des modèles.
Wilkins a dit non, Rosalind Franklin partirait dans deux mois,
après son départ, il commencerait la construction de modèles.
Je suis donc revenu à Cambridge avec ces nouvelles
et Bragg a dit "Construisez des modèles."
Bien sûr que je voulais construire des modèles.
Voici une photo de Rosalind. Elle était,
dans un sens, chimiste
mais en réalité
elle ne connaissait pas la chimie organique ou la chimie quantique.
Elle était une cristallographe.
Et je crois qu'en partie elle ne voulait pas construire de modèles
parce qu'elle n'était pas chimiste, tandis que Pauling était un chimiste.
Donc Crick et moi avons commencé à construire des modèles
et j'avais appris un peu de chimie, mais pas assez.
Nous avons trouvé la réponse le 28 février 1953.
C'était grâce à une règle qui d'après moi est une très bonne règle :
ne soyez jamais la plus brillante personne dans une pièce. Nous ne l'étions pas.
Nous n'étions pas les meilleurs chimistes dans la pièce.
Je suis entré leur montrer un couplage que j'avais fait
et Jerry Donohue - il était chimiste - a dit : "C'est faux.
Les atomes d'hydrogène sont au mauvais endroit."
Je les avais placés comme dans les livres.
Il dit qu'ils étaient faux.
Alors le lendemain, j'ai pensé : "Eh bien, il a peut être raison."
J'ai changé les emplacements et nous avons ainsi trouvé le couplage des bases.
Francis a aussitôt dit que les chaînes couraient dans des directions absolues.
Nous savions que nous avions raison.
C'était beau, vous savez, tout s'est passé en 2 heures.
De rien à quelque chose.
Nous savions que c'était important parce que, si vous couplez A avec T
et G avec C, vous avez un mécanisme de recopie.
Nous pouvions donc voir comment l'information génétique était portée.
C'est l'ordre des 4 bases.
Dans un sens, c'est une sorte d'information numérique.
Vous le copiez en procédant à la séparation des brins.
Même si ça ne marchait pas de cette façon, vous y auriez cru parce qu'il n'y avait
aucun autre procédé.
(Rires)
Ce n'est pas ainsi que la majorité des scientifiques pensent.
La plupart des scientifiques sont vraiment plutôt ennuyeux.
Ils ont dit : "Nous n'y réfléchirons que quand nous saurons que c'est vrai."
Nous pensions que c'était au moins vrai à 95% ou 99%.
Pensez-y. Les 5 années suivantes,
il n'y a eu qu'environ 5 références
à notre travail dans Nature - rien.
Nous étions donc laissés à nous-mêmes,
essayant de compléter la dernière partie de ce trio :
qu'est-ce que cette information génétique fait ?
C'était assez évident qu'elle fournissait l'information
à une molécule d'ARN mais ensuite comment passer de l'ARN à la protéine ?
Durant environ 3 ans, j'ai essayé de résoudre la structure de l'ARN.
Sans rendement. Ça ne donnait pas de bons clichés aux rayons X.
J'étais assez malheureux ; une fille m'avait refusé en mariage.
C'était vraiment, vous savez, une période merdique.
(Rires)
Voici donc une photo de Francis et moi avant que je rencontre la fille,
c'est pourquoi j'ai encore l'air heureux.
(Rires)
Ici on voit ce qu'on a fait quand on ne savait pas
par où avancer : on a créé un club nommé le Club des Cravates ARN.
George Gamow, aussi un grand physicien, il a conçu la cravate.
Il était un des membres. La question était :
comment passer d'un code à 4 lettres
au code à 20 lettres des protéines ?
Feynman était un membre, et Teller, et des amis de Gamow.
C'est la seule, non, nous avons été photographiés 2 fois.
Les 2 fois, l'un de nous n'avait pas sa cravate.
Là c'est Francis en haut à droite,
et Alex Rich - le médecin-viré-cristallographe - est à mes côtés.
Cette photo a été prise à Cambridge en septembre 1955.
Mon sourire est un peu forcé, je crois,
parce que cette fille que j'avais, elle m'avait quitté pour de bon.
(Rires)
Je n'ai pas vraiment été heureux avant 1960
parce que c'est alors que nous avons trouvé
qu'il existait trois formes d'ARN.
Nous savions, fondamentalement, que l'ADN fournit l'information à l'ARN.
L'ARN fournit l'information aux protéines.
Ce qui a permis à Marshall Nirenberg de prendre de l'ARN synthétique
et de le placer dans un système fabriquant une protéine. Il a fait de la polyphénylalanine,
Ce fut le premier déchiffrage du code génétique
et c'était tout terminé avant 1966.
Voilà, c'est ce que Chris voulait que je vous raconte.
Que s'est-il passé depuis ?
Eh bien, il faudrait que je reprenne à partir de cette période.
Après avoir trouvé la structure de l'ADN, j'ai présenté ma première conférence
au Cold Spring Harbor. Le physicien Leo Szilard
m'a regardé et m'a dit "Allez vous breveter ça ?"
Il connaissait la loi des brevets et savait que nous ne pouvions pas le breveter
parce que vous ne pouviez pas. Aucun usage à cela.
(Rires)
Ainsi l'ADN n'est pas devenue une molécule utile
et les avocats ne sont pas entrés dans l'équation avant 1973.
20 ans plus tard, lorsque Boyer et Cohen à San Francisco
et Stanford sont arrivés avec leur méthode pour l'ADN recombinant :
Stanford l'a brevetée et a fait beaucoup d'argent.
Au moins ont-ils breveté quelque chose
qui pouvait faire des choses utiles.
Ils ont ensuite appris à lire les lettres du code.
Et, boum, nous avons eu, l'industrie des biotech.
On était toujours loin de pouvoir
répondre à la question qui avait dominé mon enfance,
qui était : comment faire de l'inné-acquis ?
Je continue. J'ai déjà dépassé mon temps de parole...
Voici Michael Wigler, un mathématicien très très ingénieux
devenu physicien. Il a développé une technique
nous permettant essentiellement de regarder un échantillon d'ADN
et, finalement, à un million d'emplacements tout le long.
Il y a une puce là, une puce conventionnelle. Ensuite, il y en a une
faite par photolithographie par une société de Madison
appelée NimbleGen, très en avance sur Affymetrix.
Nous utilisons leur technique.
Vous pouvez comparer l'ADN de segments normaux et cancéreux.
Vous pouvez voir en haut
que les cancers ont des insertions ou des manques.
Cet ADN est vraiment mal foutu,
tandis que si vous avez une chance de survivre,
l'ADN n'est pas aussi de travers.
Nous croyons que ceci nous mènera finalement à ce qu'on nomme
des "biopsies d'ADN". Avant tout traitement anti-cancer,
vous devriez vraiment considérer cette technique,
pour avoir une idée de la tête de l'ennemi.
Il s'agit d'un coup d'oeil partiel
mais je crois que ce sera très, très utile.
Nous avons donc commencé avec le cancer du sein
parce qu'il y de l'argent pour ça, pas de l'argent du gouvernement.
Maintenant j'ai une sorte d'intérêt :
je veux le faire pour le cancer de la prostate.
Vous savez que vous n'êtes pas traités s'il n'est pas dangereux.
Wigler, après les cellules cancéreuses, a aussi observé les cellules normales
et il a fait une observation plutôt surprenante.
C'est que, nous avons tous environ 10 endroits dans notre génome
où nous avons perdu un gène ou en avons un autre ajouté.
Nous sommes donc tous imparfaits. La question est donc,
si nous sommes encore ici,
ces petites pertes ou ajouts ne sont peut-être pas trop mauvais.
Si ces pertes ou ajouts se produisent dans le mauvais gène,
nous serons peut-être malades.
La première maladie que nous avons étudiée a été l'autisme.
Ce choix de l'autisme venait de ce que nous avions l'argent pour le faire.
S'occuper un individu coûte 3 000 dollars. Les parents d'un enfant
ayant le syndrome d'Asperger, l'autisme de haute intelligence,
avaient envoyé ceci à une compagnie conventionnelle ; ils ne l'ont pas fait.
Ils ne pouvaient pas avec la génétique conventionnelle mais en l'examinant
nous avons commencé à trouver les gènes de l'autisme.
Vous pouvez voir ici, il y en a plusieurs.
Ainsi, plusieurs enfants autistes sont autistes
parce qu'ils ont simplement perdu un gros morceau d'ADN.
Je veux dire : un gros morceau au niveau moléculaire.
Nous avons vu chez un enfant autiste
environ 5 millions de bases manquantes à l'un de ses chromosomes.
Nous n'avons pas encore observé les parents mais les parents n'ont probablement
pas cette perte car ils ne seraient pas parents.
Ainsi, notre étude de l'autisme ne fait que commencer. Nous avons 3 millions de dollars.
Je pense qu'il en faudra au moins 10 ou 20 avant de pouvoir
aider les parents qui ont un enfant autiste
ou qui croient qu'ils pourraient avoir un enfant autiste.
à repérer la différence.
Cette même technique devrait probablement observer tout.
C'est une merveilleuse façon de trouver des gènes.
Je vais conclure en disant que
nous avons observé 20 personnes souffrant de schizophrénie.
Nous pensons qu'il faudrait en observer plusieurs centaines
avant de voir le tableau d'ensemble mais, comme vous pouvez voir,
il y en a 7 sur 20 avec des changements prononcés.
Pourtant, dans les contrôles, il n'y en avait que 3.
Que signifient donc ces contrôles ?
Étaient-ils aussi fous et nous ne le savions pas?
Ou bien, étaient-ils normaux ? Je dirais qu'ils sont normaux.
Nous croyons donc qu'en schizophrénie, il y a des gènes qui prédisposent
et, si celui-ci en est un qui prédispose,
il n'y a alors seulement qu'un sous-segment de la population
qui serait capable de devenir schizophrène.
Maintenant, nous n'avons pas encore les preuves
mais je crois, pour vous donner une hypothèse bien fondée,
que si vous êtes gaucher, vous êtes caution à la schizophrénie.
30% des gens schizophrènes sont gauchers
et la schizophrénie a une drôle de génétique.
C'est que 60% des gens sont génétiquement gauchers
mais ce n'est apparent que pour la moitié. Je n'ai pas le temps d'élaborer.
Parmi les gens qui pensent être droitiers,
il y a des génétiquement gauchers. Je le mentionne car si vous pensez :
"Oh, je n'ai pas le gène gaucher de sorte que mes
enfants ne seront pas à risque pour la schizophrénie. Vous pourriez. OK ?"
(Rires)
C'est donc, pour moi, une période extraordinaire et excitante.
Nous devrions pouvoir trouver le gène de la bipolarité ;
il y a un rapport.
Si j'avais assez d'argent, nous pourrions tous les trouver dès cette année.
Je vous remercie.